welcome thank you for taking the time to
hear some of our thoughts on current and
future
storage trends rust malkura I'm senior
manager for eBay Inc freed Avari is one
of my architects together responsible
for the roadmap the vision for the
strategy the architecture as well as the
day-to-day operations for eBay Inc
including paypal ebay marketplaces and
associated adjacencies so you know when
we think about the vision and trying to
define where we want to be in in three
years we try to think about three years
out where we want to try to meet the
trends and where we want to take our
data center we get some of our
inspiration from looking at you know
what our platform not only from what our
platform is demanding we also look at
the market what's going on we we talked
a lot with industry and we probably have
about 100 nda's and well I can't talk
specifically about anything we do get a
sense of general trends that are going
on what kind of technologies are have
the best chance of coming to market but
you know an interesting thing is you can
also look at other systems outside of
the industry for inspiration such as you
know we look at very dense storage
systems in in nature for instance when
you look at how much storage capacity is
within the human body as far as storing
within our DNA you know it's a very
dense system stores a lot of data you
have a DNA matrix or a double helix
which stores base pairs each base pair
represents two bits you need four of
those for a bite all in all if you look
at all the chromosomes in a Cell there
are six billion base pairs and given
that the average human body has about
100 trillion cells that's 150 zettabytes
in a single in a single human body so
when you we don't really have the the
system's today to really manipulate and
other the tools to really manipulate at
that level you know but we are we are
able to work at the
the nano scale and there are some
interesting technologies when you look
at things like technologies like carbon
nanotubes they are very similar to the
structure of DNA with chromosome the the
width is in the angstroms but the length
is a macroscale its measured in meters
if you stretched it out as in a single
cell it's very similar to two carbon
nanotubes very narrow but also measured
in macro when you when you expand it it
can be at a macro scale in length so
these technology or that's a very
similar manmade technology that we can
potentially leverage in the future to to
build very dense storage systems that
are reliable so when talking about the
the ebay platform and where it's taking
us and what we need to build for our
customers we do have a no a base model
or an operational level agreement so
when our customers come to us it's it's
about requirements around I ops latency
capacity as well as cost so when we have
a model like that we need to have a lot
of flexibility in all these different
storage tiers that we offer for us we do
depend on OpenStack there was an
announcement in March that paypal is now
one hundred percent OpenStack ebay is
also is also getting there as well but
you know when we need to have the
flexibility because a lot of times these
applications are not really coming in at
the right ear or life cycle of the data
changes so we need to be able to move
very very nimble e without having any
impact of the applications above between
the different tiers very often data is
very active when its young and then that
same data will as it gets older it gets
colder very quickly so looking at the
biggest tenant in the environment to the
eBay marketplace 255 billion in gross
merchandise volume on the site it has
one
52 million users it is a platform that
is a kind of a neutral arbiter of them
in the market we're not competing with
the sellers when the so one big area
that's a I've been growing for us is the
the mobile side so while the site baby
growing at about ten percent a year the
mobile side is growing sixty to seventy
percent and this has some this has had
some implications in storage for sure
now paypal is a a payment platform
allows buyers and sellers to do payments
so easily safely 193 countries that
operates in 25 different currencies now
if you look at the market as far as the
top million sites this is very similar
tech that does a comparison of payment
technologies whether it's 10 to the top
10 case I it's the top 100 k sides and
top million active sites paypal is the
most commonly used payment technology
out there and then the other major
entity is a GSR ebay enterprise it does
digital marketing multi-channel
retailing for some of the big brands
such as a Toys R Us sports authority a
lot of common brands that you might be
aware of our running within our platform
on ebay enterprise enabled platform and
then there's all the adjacencies now
these there's about 50 of them we just
bought pay tiant they're coming in all
the time they expect a certain level of
experience that they're used to working
with public clouds working within kolos
they you know they need to have that
seamless experience that we need to be
able to offer a very competitive storage
and compute platform for them to build
on to encourage them to come on so
looking at the 2018 vision looking three
years out these are the key areas that
we see as needing as where we want to
pay attention the first is we call flash
everywhere now it doesn't mean that
we're we're buying flash but we look at
every area that we're buying
storage and we say well we like the TCO
characteristics of flash what is that
point where it makes sense what are the
costs points the inflection points where
it makes sense to put flash in that
environment and then we work with
suppliers and this would be areas like
big data where hasn't traditionally been
in where we can build those products and
those technologies to actually get and
realize those those TCO those other
benefits besides performance with flash
multiple flash tears yes flash storage
is compared to flash animation yes yes
yes flash stores man essentially so
multiple flash tears or man this you
know we have performance man today but
we're also working on we call Big Data
flash or big data and which is where we
made some compromises and performance to
get give back on price you're also going
to see more processing capabilities
being closer to the media maybe some arm
processors right next to the media doing
things like you know basic storage
capabilities like encryption or
compression but also being able to run
maybe software really near to the stores
things like an object storage and OSD
near the the device and serving object
storage directly so storage class or
storage class memory memory class
storage depending on it's really about
universal storage or the blurring of the
lines between memory and non-volatile
storage there are technologies that
we're interested in that we're keeping
an eye on that we think that could be
have some potential here and we'll talk
about some of that so storage densities
hitting a petabyte in a rack unit
typical rack would be one would be about
40 to 48 rack units or about W about 50
or just 50 rack units as well that we
have that would be about 50 petabytes it
on in a single rack
the technologies that will help us get
there are going to be things like 3d
NAND or some of these storage class
memories so now the goal there is to one
as we shrink down we get some cost
benefits with storage and you know as
well as you know potentially these
technologies will give us mobile devices
that will be in the terabyte range right
so that would be nice so storage
networking moving to Ethernet this is
networking is a big part of storage so
we're interested in seeing how we can
leverage Ethernet and move away from
some of our fiber channel or InfiniBand
network technologies so we're looking at
the road map of Ethernet we're seeing
that there will be some convergence as
far as getting some of the reliability
from we have from the buffer to buffer
credit and fibre channel to potentially
priority flow control with an ethernet
and on the infiniband side getting some
of the infiniband protocols like RDMA or
SRP into ethernet with technologies like
RDMA over ethernet or rocky which is a
RDMA over converged ethernet yes
encryption mom this presume ebay has had
experience with this in terms of your
center of your users losing keys of that
maybe biggest planet is bring back yes
grow under storage not no plans at this
moment although they might be
interesting yeah that hasn't been a
focus for us yeah so now for you know
having these capabilities in Ethernet
you know it does reduce we have done
some testing with RDMA over ethernet we
have gotten very good Layton sees down
in the 20 micro second range so for this
is really important for the
disaggregation of storage in the future
the separation of compute from from
storage which allows us to do more
interesting things with with cloud and
big data getting a big data on the cloud
yes I'm so you have technology like I
skazhi mne fco you today was special
about in 2018 that you will see the
convergence so f fcoe so fibre channel
ver so that's not really uh we're
looking to simplify your so with the
we're looking to just really get the the
latency is down and we've seen with RDMA
that the latency czar or better we
haven't done testing with fcoe but it's
not really the trends are really going
with fcoe today right so I sir I scuzzy
over over over RDMA right so that's
something that we asked as he is in line
with what we're doing so exabytes of
analytics so our clusters are our
analyst clusters are big and we talk
about the data explosion it's really
about cold data I mean we look at the
transactional core of what we do that's
not really growing nearly as fast as our
analytics data so we have that score
maybe twenty percent your rear whereas
analytics is growing much faster than
that so we have all these big data's
your surrounding and analyzing this the
score of transactional data that's
producing it right so what can we use as
far as storage technologies to help us
reduce this big data sprawl that we're
seeing in our data centers all right so
densities are definitely going to be one
of those pushing for dead city and
storages won't be one of those areas
that we look at and then of course
hyperscale open-source clouds OpenStack
of course we're very much involved with
but how does storage play in these
environments for for myself when we are
talking to any we're looking at any
product we require that they have cinder
drivers that's just a minimum to come
into the environment we kind of think of
cinder as a kind of open API that's
common for all storage platforms so it's
been a very good development for us
because before it was like we every
vendor had their own their own API
so looking at some of the historical
trends which can can get shed some
insight on what kind of things happen to
really change the market and might open
the door for new memory guys memory
technologies so this is a this is some
data that's tracked on cost capital
costs by John Anna McCallum and he goes
back all the way to the 50s but to focus
on what we have here in the last 20
years you know there's a bunch of trends
here a bunch of bumps you know there's a
quake here that happened in Taiwan over
here in more recent history in 2011 you
see a bump and disk drive prices that
was caused by the massive floods in in
Thailand that had a much more much more
impactful situation on the market when
that happened but one of the interesting
things so the top line here is is a dims
the bottom ex is here those are hard
drives and these lines here these dashes
are our NAND flash memory and then down
here you see SSDs really coming in but
they just fall in line with with flash
pricing so does anybody know what
happened here that really different
started to have flash pull away or nan
pull away from from dens as far as
pricing there was that there was an
event that happen if anybody yeah close
but is actually a nano was it was an
apple product but that was about the
time 2005-2006 that the the Nano came
out and that's where it started really
take off there's a I pause earlier but
it was really at that point where the
the market demand and the commitment by
Apple to put in CMOS space flash into
their devices and the popularity of
those devices that created a demand and
that caused fabs to be
you know the ROI was there to invest in
fabs to create more and more of this for
the mobile market so that's really what
it's going to take if there's a new
technology out there we're at we're
going to have to get to a point where
existing technologies are not really
meeting the needs and then a market
market phenomenon these also needs to
happen where it there's an absolute need
to shift to a new memory technology
they're not they're not really
frequently coming in you can see it
means hard drives have been there
forever dram just came in there and then
flash really start breaking out but it's
not very common it's not very easy for a
new memory storage system to break into
the market so this is future looking at
the future and this is from Wikibon
estimations and they're predicting that
the green light appears is flash the red
line is hard drives and then tape which
I'm not as interested in but right these
top two lines here you're seeing a
convergence on price near 20 and the
2020s early 2020s and flash has been
depreciating thirty percent and drives
have been depreciating about seventeen
percent however for me I'm by mostly
flash today and given this capex gap
that's in between flash and disk today
there are other interesting
characteristics of solid-state that
we've been successfully able to convince
the the company that are worth looking
into or be thinking are important to
make it worth that jump to bridge that
capex gap which i call it or at least
narrow it so datacenter efficiency yes
being parallel for two years
and then dipping together than being
flat again and then dipping and then
being flat again and dipping ending but
is there some inherent reason why the
progress is made in both industries a
two-year the list yeah actually this is
a wiki bonds predictions I'm not exactly
sure why or how they came to the flatter
lines for those technologies I think
they're just not evolving as quickly
it's getting more difficult with with
the drives to advance them to the next
level no there's a god I can't I can't
explain why why that is yes I'm back
stage without the advances in both the
magnetic recording and I SCMS I this you
know those are some more like optical or
optical type or SEM you're talking this
is not talking to CM that mean it's not
major market right now but I'll talk
some about about that as well that's
those are kind of the those are the
technologies that are waiting waiting
for NAND to hit the wall and they're
just kind of I call them in the on-deck
circle you know just kind of waiting for
their chance and in something like maybe
an apple kind of you know making
commitment to one of those technologies
or a big buyer Apple's one of the
biggest buyers right now well is really
what it's going to take to create the
market so data center efficiency is
something we care about operational
costs matter not just capex and too
often when buyers are looking at storage
technologies are looking at just the
capex costs but you do have to care
about this stuff as well this is power
this is carbon footprint these are
things that we measure ourselves by our
KPIs so you know these are some of the
measurements we take this is actually
one of our our data centers it runs off
of fuel fuel cell technology for the
primary power source so we try to do we
can to to have a green data center and
when you dig down into these metrics you
start looking at well what's
you know what's going to these metrics
and a lot of big piece of that is the
storage technology and so if there's a
flash has thirty to sixty percent more
efficiency and power that's something
that comes into the equation for our
decision and narrows that capex gap and
also can depend on where you're
deploying your data centers now for a
data center deployment you have to have
a combination of good internet
connectivity as well as you have to have
a good good power reliability so
typically these are the areas where a
lot of data centers are deployed for
deploying in Japan the cost is very
expensive it's going to it's going to
definitely go factor into your equation
more when you're deciding to buy flash
or not whereas if you're buying in the
western US where power is relatively
cheap it's probably the only area and in
a world where power is somewhat stable
you know it's not as much but it's still
important so looking at that capital
cost model we look at flash in hard
drives it doesn't really make sense just
looking at capital costs that's the the
cost the networking and the cost of the
actual cost the devices but when you
look at the the general TCO then you
look at the power you look at also a big
factor is a fr the failure rate is very
critical in in our calculations as well
we do find in our experience we were
running a lot of flash for several years
the failure rates of flash have been
much lower than in spinning media and
that you know you start thinking about
things like well you know a lot of my
activity and my data center is going
into replacing drives and I can have be
closer to a hands-free data center you
know if I deploy more flash in there so
you look at that the operational costs
it really starts to look more equivalent
in cost and then when you factor and of
course the I ops or how you're using it
are using flash then it can be even more
compelling to
point where you may have to buy a lot
more shelves of hard drives in order to
make up what you get for flash so we see
about point to AFR so annual failure
rate with flash and it's about 1.2 for
the for the spinning media today but
there are there are some other factors
that we haven't had we haven't been
running it as long so we don't you know
we don't really know exactly how it's
going to fail at the end of its life
however one thing that's unique about
Flash's we can actually tell how much
when it's going to die we can predict a
little easier because we can see how
many drive rights have been going on and
we know what it's rated for all right so
that's that's nice it's a little less
it's a little more predictable in that
way point2 and uh believe it was a point
Oh point one two yeah it might have been
high on the unlit on the drives but yeah
percent per year here so looking at the
different kinds of flash you know we
have this little illustration about how
the where happens and the difficulty the
challenge with flash going forward is
really about endurance endurance is the
main issue when we look at slc which is
a single bit per cell MLC duel and TLC
which is three bits you know if you look
at it in a drinking contest or a
drinking game you know you say to
bartender someone says the bartender hey
I want two bits in my mlc and they fill
it up and if you guess right when you
look at you guess right then you take
the shot if you can you keep doing that
and as soon as you can't read it anymore
is it starts a the lines start to blur
with your vision as well as they get to
get worn and then eventually you're not
able to read is accurately anymore so
with slc it's a lot easier to tell
whether it's full
or not but as you get down to TLC it
gets more more difficult more quickly
right so this is some of the challenge
they're missin TLC a while it gives you
the density you're losing out on
endurance and it's a balance disclaimer
there I'm not recommending you play this
game so a big problem for for flash and
the market is we treat flash like as
disc too often the flash is flash it's
not disc it's playing on is playing on a
field that's really built with rules
around disc and optimizations for disc
some of those optimizations the areas
that we can improve on our you know have
Colonels and file systems and they're
all expecting discs and they all treat
the media the storage media like it's
like as a disc so for instance when we
looked at okay what can we if we have
flash that's fast enough like if we have
nvme which is a very very fast protocol
for drives replacing SAS potentially
we've seen Layton sees in the twenty
microseconds range you know if we have a
very fast storage device and we wanted
to use it to extend memory relatively
cheaply and maybe get more hypervisors
on two or more VMs onto a hypervisor you
know could we do that well the challenge
is it the Colonel's treat when they page
out they page out large pages
sequentially and they're not really
treating it in a more more optimal way
for flash right so that's one challenge
and then the other is with application
so we grew up through flash into one of
our search applications we found that we
weren't getting we were getting better
performance but we weren't getting what
we expect for twice the cost so we
looked at it we found out they were
buffering all their rights and then
doing a single sequential stream out to
the disc or what they thought was disc
and that wasn't really you know if it
did a little more random parallelization
in which would be a lot faster it would
have been much better and taken
advantage of of the flash others are
with controllers flash does not fail the
same way as discs yet we we treat it
like that we treat it like it's family
this we have enough level provisioning
when it hits hits down hits to that
level that we fail the whole thing now
you know flash you we've done some
testing and we've said okay you know
take some random flash it has a certain
amount of programmer erase cycles which
is those those pores in the drink and
just run it run it until it fails right
and we found is that the flash if it's
something worse rated for say X program
were very cycles we could actually run
it for TX and we'd still have about
seventy percent of the flash that was
usable and so we're just we're throwing
that away you know at fortieth at the
point we were really did so we're we can
still use it it seems like a waste you
know maybe there's maybe we should treat
it more like it's it's like a gas tank
like it's just it's reducing over time
instead of just throwing out so much
good good flash so the other areas uh
you know anything actually in other
areas of you know if we're running TLC
and it's starting to get to the point
where it's getting hard to read you know
we could do some more creative things
about while we can re represent the
flash you know make it maybe we make it
look like mlc you know and we can read
that a little bit better right and then
when that gets bad we can change into
slc and we can just re reprogram the
flash to have a little more endurance
and keep it a lot longer so those are
some things i'd like to see as well and
then of course software-defined storage
lot of it out there especially the open
store stuff is not optimized for for
flash at all we've done testing sorry in
the back oh whoa gafford
when you talk about wearing up splash
man do you think in normal use that it
would actually wear out before it's
obsolete does you'd want to replace it
with something higher density yes I mean
that is it depends right i mean if that
is definitely something if it depending
on how long you can make it last right
but you know yeah it's just having that
flexibility i think is useful you know
so if you're running if you have body
made this investment and you can move
your your TLC deployment into an slc
deployment where you need more
performance you now have that option
right instead of just throwing it away
right now but yeah you could there could
be newer technologies that you might
want to move to just solo those a little
sex anymore I'm gonna wash device fails
it's it's it's replaced yeah yeah also
the the vendors do yeah I don't know
they could be repackaging it and turning
it into you know thumb drives or
something but yeah it's a you know as
far as is how those the market treats it
today how lot of the flash devices and
arrays treated today as they go all the
way yes 30 question you don't want to be
running filling double your data centers
over you and so different vendors powers
until I think footprint matters to and
so he's job probably from TLC to slc it
was already a little good as the device
because an old announced he's worse yeah
so yeah not matter that it's still got
good because you can't disguise
yeah that's true that you know if I'm
buying slc I don't know I no longer need
to because I have a supply coming in
right for my more high-performance
workloads and we do characterize and we
do have we would call it I up per
terabyte measurement that we have for
all of our all of our workloads so I
could be buying for for the TLC use
cases and then as it cycles out I could
move that into the slc environments or
mlc so I'm not buying slc anymore from
things that are hiding from you late for
the flash controller is doing the
garbage collection that will happen I
think so the applications you coulda
cared about a latency and so on yeah
they may and will have to put it on my
appropriate location if they are that
sensitive and we do have some very
sensitive applications especially in the
in the fraud detection space that really
the lower the latency the better but
we'll just we'll just make sure we're
putting it on the right the right media
right but there's a lot I mean talking
about like big data there's a lot more
use cases that are that are not as
latency sensitive so big data flash so
you know we we got we heard a lot of
performance performance performance
right and so say okay we're sold on the
performance but we like the other
aspects of flash and we like the power
like them so we ruined back to the
vendors and we gave them all the
requirement we said look we give back on
performance give me back something on
cost right so that way I can deploy more
flash in more areas so we said you know
basically just just nearly beat the
drives beat the enterprise your line
enterprise drives and I'm using in my
Hadoop environments don't blow them away
so you know we figured out that a 30
cent per gigabyte target is about the
time were really the point where the
inflection point where it really makes
sense to to replace all the near line
drives so you know but initially we said
okay we don't really need that at first
but that's the roadmap we want to get to
is thirty cents per gig for flash so now
we've been working with many of the of
the the manufacturers to to give us some
of that so for instance in a
software-defined this could be Hadoop a
software-defined storage situation could
be Hadoop could be sup
typically do a three replica model and
if you're paying for near line drives
enterprise drives about 25 cents per gig
this is all just sample costs not our
actual ones you pay about 75 cents but
say you introduce a flash replica and
then you start moving you can move what
your workloads their potentially get
better capabilities and now you can move
your other replicas to to a lower tier
or a consumer-grade drive which is much
much cheaper so now getting better
performance characteristics and you're
able to maintain the cost structure so
that's something we're actively Rackley
doing today in our in our
software-defined storage areas current
for wish kind of uh so thirty cents
Brooking a bit right yes hello Ram yeah
so I can see there there's some products
that are that have just been recently
announced one of them was a the sandisk
infini flash and a few if you heard it
was released a couple couple months ago
that was that was one that now that we
were interested in they I believe they
announced it at about a dollar a gig as
the as the public price so that's that's
what we would term as a big date of
flash right was that's what we define it
changes a ace MOSFET assaulted that's
when a mystery to this day yeah they
would be they typically do a softer side
saw earlier yeah there's none not the
hardware level yeah I'd like to actually
be have the ability to even just remove
replicas you know we just have more
flexibility with the software storage
models to control the cost a lot better
especially its data ages we want to make
sure we can put like maybe two copies on
cold storage and keep one that's active
for the occasional person needs to do a
bugfix
so in the other trend were seen as the
commoditization of flash arrays there's
a kind of do it yourself you know build
your own flash rays and there's a lot of
technologies out there there's very
dense media for terabyte two and a half
inch drives you have this other one is a
neat terabyte custom form factor and
when you start getting away again going
back to where we treat flashes disk well
we're still using disk form factors
we're starting to get away from that too
or we can get a lot more density if we
do custom form factors with flash and
then you have very dense storage
enclosures that you can build something
thick this one on on the bottom left
here is a 60 drive 62 and half inch
drive to you enclosure there's actually
even denser ones coming out and the
other one is a day before just a this is
the infinite flash product that is 512
terabytes in three you which is probably
one of the densest flash products out
there and these have a roadmap you know
they're they're going to go even denser
you know with as flash advances is the
media gets denser they're going to go to
a petabyte and three you so that density
has a lot of implications for just
saving on data center space especially
if the cost is the right the right place
and then software-defined storage of
course sitting on top of it when I when
I talk about software front storage I
really define it as I control the
hardware relationship with my vendor and
I'm only really buying software anymore
from from the storage vendors and many
of them are going in that direction so
even so just today we have arrays that
are 180 terabyte Center in Iraq in Iraq
unit as a normalizing Iraq unit coconut
you see more pcie versus traditional
sauna
well yours we're starting to see more
I'm more hopeful for envy me that's
there's not it's there's a premium right
now on it but I think as more at next
half of the year we're going to see more
computers right now it's Intel and there
are products that have that are that do
have nvme drives in them I think some of
the actually there's a lot of Dell an
Oracle have some but once the new vent
the new competitors get in the product
four or five of them in the next half of
the year I think you're really going to
start to see competing with SAS and
potentially because there's no real like
as far as I cost him any fashion ring
it's actually it should be better and
you're removing that SAS layer which is
introducing a lot of latency I scuzzy or
a peep he was kind of promoting wrong
scuzzy / pti cut I guess you were born
insanity over over over Ethernet as well
yes just kind of seeing some at the NVA
is really it's really designed for for
flash in mine so like I think we're
gonna move away from well maybe not move
away but they might get supplanted with
some of these with these all the older
protocols which were designed for for
more discs but envy I think nvme as the
is the the future here so storage class
memory so this as I said this is kind of
the on deck circle waiting for their
opportunity they all have various
characteristics so spin-spin tronox or
SCT Ram this is looking at the the spin
of electrons and the the polarity and
determining the bit the bit of data from
that and controlling it through a
magnetic field it's been around for some
time not not a lot of practical
applications and then there you have
phase change memory so this is where you
have a
substance or it's a glass-like substance
that is amorphous and you fit with
through thermal reaction you can change
it from crystalline to non-crystalline
and that represents your bid right so it
has it has some issues around power it
takes a lot of heat since you're you're
basing it on thermal activity so that's
that's been all cern in research for a
long time but it still i think it's it's
not really going to be something that
we're going to see in the near future as
far as products the 1i have the most
hope for is the one on the web here the
the resistive Ram and there's various
forms of it but essentially it's a
filament which creates a which enables a
current between two cells and whether
it's on it on or offer the resistance
that's the measure between it is really
what determines your bit there so you
have companies like HP has memory stirs
nant arrows carbon nanotube RAM and then
there's a crossbar I think these this
technology actually is you will start to
see some products in the next year or
two and this has a lot of promise
because it has it doesn't have the
endurance issues that flash does but it
doesn't have the mindshare right now
that flash has as well so they're going
to the the manufactures the fabs are
really going to push nand as far as they
can and right now they're looks like as
long as there's a road map there and
with 3d nand where you know if you take
a 3d nand is where if you take em if you
imagine the the cells and TLC mlc in
planar nand so it's on in one dimension
and you know a single slc would be like
one person living in a house mlc will be
two and then TLC be three well now
you're making a skyscraper right you're
building up from that and so we're there
are products out there are chips out
there that are at a three layer right
now
potentially four-layer coming up well
those those will get us to those will 3x
or 4x to the the density that we're
getting out of those those chips and
potentially get us to start talking
about terabyte and phones so with that
I'll hand it over to freed we'll talk
about some of the applications thank you
and I'm just going to take a step back a
talk a little bit about you know the
company and the road we've been on
starting in two thousand nine and up to
today and and then you know we're going
to go as part of the presentation we're
going to go into are some of the data
center designs and also we can also talk
about some of the solutions and
challenges that we see in our
environment especially you know the
newer trends that we are seeing in our
data centers and the type of problems
that we're trying to solve so back in
two thousand nine I think you know so
this is a slide that I got from our CEO
and you know he you know he really likes
to talk about the journey that we were
on and and the journey started back in
two thousand nine so coming forward you
know with the introduction of the mobile
you know technology really you know the
whole ecommerce and commerce kind of
blur together and you know we're talking
about commerce now and you know it
includes you know everything from you
know brick and mortar all the way to
online shopping so imagine if you walk
in a shop and then you know you're in
the market to purchase a pair of shoes
or maybe a jacket you can walk into a
shop you look at the merchandise you try
it on and right then and there you can
scan the barcode on your phone and try
to see if you can get a better deal
online so so you see how the the whole
commerce is changing and and how you
know there are different dynamics so as
far as the data center is concerned you
know it has to be able to support a
different type of workload different
type of
environment and different tab different
types of use cases so it's more of an
omni-channel type of environment right
now that we're dealing with and it also
you know from the business perspective
it actually puts a lot of different
perspectives into how branding is done
how companies are are doing the brands
on there under you know merchandise and
you know the same way we have a you know
social networking you know type of site
we're going to have a social business
where you know the information is
flowing and all the brands are kind of
you know coming together and also you
know what what the user actually
provides is total access to the to the
user profile and the purchase behaviors
and also what happens is you know with
the with the mobile technology you know
as you're walking through a mall for
example you know the different merchants
can actually send you different kinds of
offers depending on your the
localization where you are and also the
analytics behind you know what type of
purchases you've been doing and you know
your user behavior and things like that
so the whole the whole commerce
landscape has changed and as a result of
that you know the infrastructure that
supports that landscape also needs to
change so there are a few a few data
center trends that I like to talk about
so one of them is obviously like Ross
was mentioning you know the explosive
growth in storage you know all these
information that supports you know the
commerce ecommerce and the whole you
know the whole ecosystem is basically a
it's explosive growth in in storage so
you know we need to be very you know we
have to actually come up with with
different type of technologies and get
very creative when it comes to storage
technologies especially for big data
analytics and you know the whole aspect
of you know object store with a
disaggregation model and you know the
whole new you know the no sequel trend
where you have you know different type
of
ruptured data that you need to deal with
and and the technology is behind that so
one of the initiatives that we are
actually driving as part of this
explosive growth in storage one of the
initiatives is this aggregation of
storages and compute because as you have
a storage and compute in one box every
time you add storage you automatically
add compute and vice versa so in some
environments your very storage bound and
you have to keep adding storage but you
know by default you're buying CPU as
well or if you have a CPU bound
environment you don't want to keep
adding storage to the environment so you
know this aggregation is there and the
disaggregation is something that needs
to be dealt with that needs to be dealt
with and they need to be scaled and
refreshed independently as part of that
you know once you disaggregate your
storage a lot of load goes on the
network as the storage and the network
as the storage and compute are in the
same box all the traffic you know
obviously flows over the bus either the
SAS bus or the pci bus but you know as
you disaggregate these then you have to
rethink how you do the networking and
and how much cost it actually adds to
the whole infrastructure and scale out
solutions obviously at scale are always
a TCO conversation so that comes in mind
and you know every time you talk about
that give you an give you an idea of our
environment so you know it grows twenty
percent year-over-year and for you know
for the oltp environment and i'm going
to get into the details of our
environments look like different silos
that we have so in our oltp environment
we have about twenty percent growth but
we get a three hundred percent growth in
your analytics environment and we need
to deal with that you know as part of
the infrastructure team so this is the
size of our managed infrastructure so we
have a sand environment based on fibre
channel handles or oltp transactional
environment it's about 80 petabytes of
that we have a huge six better by
nazz implementation and object store
about 30 petabytes and analytic
environment you know we're anticipating
close to one exabyte 5 2016 so so that's
the environment that we really have to
get our arms around as far as the size
again you know 130 sand as flash storage
arrays in three major data centers our
data centers you know one of the newer
ones is in Salt Lake City and it's a
it's you know state of the art at this
point but like you know we're mentioning
we have some density issues there we
have power issues there that we need to
address and we have about 1.4 million
peak hour I ops just in our San
environment to handle the load and we
have obviously thousands and thousands
of servers so as far as our environment
we have an old TP environment online
transactions it's primarily fibre
channel and Oracle based and there's one
of our Rick or you know legacy
environments right now one of the
environments that changes very little
but it's the bread and butter of the
company primarily you know the growth is
kind of low in that environment scale is
impaired bytes and protocols we use
their fibre channel NFS and some very
little I skazhi in that environment the
other environment we have is the no
sequel environment where we use where we
actually run Cassandra couchbase
those type of technologies and it's
usually the back end to our mobile apps
and there you know you know right now we
have a dad's model there but like I
mentioned we want to get into a
disaggregated model where we have
separate racks of storage separate racks
of CPU or compute and then we can scale
them independently that's that and the
growth there is about you know a medium
growth and it's either with dads and
it's
it's some areas we have I scuzzy and we
are trying to get to more I scuzzy in
that environment and we are trying to
get to a cinder controlled environment
we have one went one vendor sorry one
vendor in that environment that's a
disaggregated model and we use their you
know management software at this point
but we would like to eventually go to
cinder big data is the next environment
we have big data analytics primarily
Hadoop HDFS in that environment it's a
local gas model and over there also we
are investigating some disaggregation of
storage especially in that environment
most of it is storage bound we
constantly run out of storage some of
our jobs actually fail because you know
we run out of temp storage in those
environments so we have to restart our
MapReduce jobs and stuff so as part of
that we want to be disaggregated we want
to be able to allocate more storage
where we need to in seen hundred pit up
hundreds of petabytes the growth is very
high and we are actually we have a dash
model going to I skazhi and we are
considering object in that store in that
environment object store Swift safe
cinder you know those are the management
and also the private cloud that we
talked about so OpenStack kvm based
private cloud and you know tens of
petabytes in size so on and so forth but
if you look at this landscape we can
actually divide it into two separate
environments so one is our legacy
environment is san storage appliances
and the other one is actually the rest
of our environment so most of the
changes that we have at ebay get and the
new technologies they get introduced on
the right-hand side of this slide
because it's a lower risk environment
and it's not a legacy environment it
doesn't have as much baggage
and you know we can introduce change in
that environment a lot easier and you
know we can test out you know whatever
concepts we have in mind easier in this
environment so we have some key
initiatives the key initiatives that we
have in these environments basically you
know separation of storage and compute
especially for Hadoop yes storage and
compute when I moved here because this
way I'm thinking about that you have a
storage node if you're running Cassandra
any of those things you need cpu there
and the more you load it the more CPU
you need and if you're going over the
network typically even need more CPU so
you know if you say well I'll just
combine these two and make them the same
and say well maybe there is there's some
differential and the amount of CPU you
put on there i mean even a memory say on
the storage node i want lots of caching
so dear am cashing so you know if you
actually done a profile where you say my
ideal storage node is this amount of
compute this amount of DRM and that
storage and my ideal you know storage
node is some less and then it versus the
cost of networking if you mentioned
where you're putting and usually
networking as you know the expensive
stuff so you thinking the total cost of
ownership does it make sense to just
make all the notes the same and forget
this disaggregation yeah when we talk to
our application owners what they say is
that there for different type of use
cases they need a different disk to
memory ratio and they want a centralized
location where they can carve out
whatever amount of storage they need and
allocate it to these use cases basically
the conversation there is flexibility
and and you're absolutely right the cost
of the network in a disaggregated
environment is about twenty-five percent
of the entire of the entire rack so each
rack if rat cost one hundred dollars
there is a 20 to 25 dollar cost for
network yes so it doesn't matter if you
have it out on a separate rack you have
this pool of storage that you can
actually carve out as you desire and
then you can put as so that's another
exactly that's another model that you
can follow but then again you're
confined to how much storage you can fit
in a chassis if you have the storage and
the network I'm the storage and the CPU
together and if you run out of CPU you
have to buy another chassis where it can
also comes with this video with the
other component that you don't
necessarily need to add so in peril r
you say didn't cast know if I just say
it's all gonna be the same note your
same design just cookie cutter it is it
Ashley's extra car that is that so
another goal as a relic said is that
narrowing of the number of SKUs that we
have and so we look at what we're doing
in big data we really have custom skews
or we have the excuse that are built for
that that our storage heavy I'm being
able to split out some that stores some
of it it can be done through tearing but
being able to move that storage out and
you have my workload actually run on a
common skew actually simplifies things
because I can now have my big data
workloads running alongside on the same
skews as my my edge tier as my new
sequel that can now move workloads
around a lot more easily easily so
having having the ability to push all
that that intermixed cold data out of
the big data environments and have and
have a cloud or have a very elastic
really compute focused with very narrow
very uh with a limited skew with a
single skew is another thing we're
trying to achieve there
sorry easy to work with management
cuddle and run a high compute those
storage and a little computed by storage
on the same physical box then you can
get to the single skew in the same way
the box but you know with a litter box
and my drank no there's no it's there
I'll treated like cattle or not pass
right there yeah foxes anyway so the
reference point of then you would you
can think balancing you solve that
problem by work with management yes okay
I also the flexibility to actually
reallocate your CPU compute a resources
is another aspect of this whole thing so
you can have a rack of compute that you
can today you can allocate it to your
Hadoop analytics environment and run the
to dupe intensive jobs and if the
storage is disaggregated from that
environment then you can actually you
know reallocate that rack of compute to
your front end you know if you have a
high season for example in e-commerce or
you know you can you can actually move
your computer resources around without
having to move your storage resources
around it gives you flexibility it gives
you a you know a way of reallocating
your resources or reusing your resources
in a way so as far as the key
initiatives again you know the
disaggregation is one big initiative we
have a software-defined storage so we
have the ability right now to actually
contract manufacturers some of our
storage boxes we also interact with a
lot of storage vendors out there and you
know we try to you know allocate a time
to influence the road maps and you know
somehow ask for the type of
products that we would need to consume
in the future and so so when we get
these solutions in it's just an it's
just a box with it it's just a storage
box so we need some kind of a software
to actually run on top of these
environments whether it's a contract
manufactured environment or any other
environment then you know we need some
kind of like a management layer of
software on top of these boxes and with
software-defined storage you know we can
actually do these you know these type of
stuff and software-defined networking
obviously is another aspect of it you
know because for this whole
disaggregation to come in play you know
we need both sdn and software-defined
solutions and eventually the goal is to
actually move to a cloud ola based SLA
based app of as a service environment so
one of the initiatives that on the for
the dbas for example right now for the
database team is to provide database as
a service in your private cloud you know
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service software as a service and
eventually you know database as a
service and it all needs to be
self-managed that's where we get to
complete flexibility in our environment
as part of this then you know once you
become disaggregated in your environment
you know the next question is the data
tiering you don't want to keep all your
data in one tier especially for your
Hadoop analytics environment where you
have maybe five to ten percent of your
data active and hard and as time goes on
it becomes warm and then you gotta you
know movie to archive and eventually
cold you know keeping the data in one
tier becomes very expensive at scale so
you know the next obvious step would be
to do a data tiering strategy and you
know we're actually working with some
software startups software companies to
provide data tiering for our Hadoop
analytics environment based on the
information that's it that's the
and you know heat maps and policy-driven
basically and again it ties into our TCO
models and all that stuff so you know
the model that we have right now is what
we used to have is basically individual
servers with with that so you know
direct attached storage in each server
and that was a model that worked for us
before we scale to this size and now
we're seeing that you know keeping all
the data on the same layer is not is not
economical so we have actually starting
this year we move to this model where we
keep our hot data inside the server and
then we try to actually offload some of
that data where we think we don't need
anymore at that point in time we offload
it to a lower cost platform in the
infrastructure and that has saved us a
lot of money you know that the TCO that
they ran is around 20 to 30 million
dollars only by doing that you know
we're actually shipping off some of the
data into into our cold soda speaks
environment but the goal is to actually
get here where we have a really thin hot
a layer of data inside our store inside
our servers and then you know we have a
warm layer and we have a very cold layer
of data which is usually over a year old
but we still need to keep you around
with e-commerce you know you need to be
able to go back here over year so for
example this year holiday season we need
to be able to see what last year's
holiday season numbers and trends were
or the year before so every year we need
to actually go back and look at the data
that we haven't probably touched in
about a year so the data needs to stay
around but not necessarily on the same
tier so what we see that basically is a
triangle like this as far as what
storage technologies are concerned
yes the illustrations suggest that the
TCO baby of the same or maybe there is
not much difference because you seem to
be moving costs and out there you'll
need it won't be here in a battle
network in order to accommodate this
aggravation that you if you have any
sense of how much it fxstc you by moving
on to this one so in fact that we were
actually keeping the hot layer inside
the server we are confining the network
traffic we don't even go over the
network that much we just access the
data that we need inside the server
still and and the data that we
infrequently access actually get teared
off so so the network overhead there is
not as much as if you had a total
disaggregated model it will be very hard
to love it but I do districts but what's
hot and what's going yes so for
different use cases is different this
model we are actually implementing only
for our Hadoop analytics environment at
this point and there we have a very it's
a standard tap of pattern that we follow
and there another general right so your
data is more active when its first
ingested into the cluster so we just had
adjusted on to the hot tier process it
keep it there for maybe a month but when
you look at the total size of the
cluster keep that month's worth of data
is really not that big so it's not a
heavy heavy investment it might be a
couple racks right so and then what
happens to the that area is not growing
as fast that that active data set is not
growing as fast as that cold data set
but now you're you're investing in it
they actually cost less to expand that
that cool data sets right that's where
we start getting gaining that the TCO
really starts making sense and we say a
lot of money because all I'm buying is
cold yeah the data management is become
over time becomes the cold data
management you know how you manage the
data that you need to
around and and it's cold but still needs
to reside somewhere yes sure what's the
API to the day of Turing like your case
if I'm going to run some application
wants to reanalyze what last holiday
season is does that application or me
have to say hole in this stuff from cold
storage or do I just try to access it
and it just me right we try to access
your data and the software layer the
tiering software that i was talking
about correct it actually is intelligent
enough to bring back this stuff that
gets frequent access after a certain
point of time so we are looking at some
intelligent software based on heat maps
and based on policies that we said to
actually do the data movement between
these tears so the application doesn't
have to be aware of what's going on
underneath oh they season I dragon all
this stuff and nobody's going to look at
it again for a long time so I have to
you have to distinguish between
something that's so mark ival that just
got sniped once a year from things that
are brought in that somebody discovered
is very interesting so lesson so that's
where the policy comes in you know the
way you set the policies you can say if
a piece of data is accessed up you know
more than five times in a day then bring
it back or if it's accessed once I want
it back immediately depends on your use
case and the type of policy you sit but
if the policy is to actually as soon as
you access any piece of data that's been
aged off you want to bring it back all
the way then of course there is overhead
and premium to pay that's that's for
sure or you start accessing the data in
case the holiday do you once they know
that we're getting the date of monday or
october obtains data printer ever yeah
that would be another policy to set
probably yes so so that that piece of
software that actually does the turing
it can get very sophisticated you know
depending on what what level of
functionality and capabilities you want
it to have location doesn't see that
request the you know the data and again
like I said this is just for our Hadoop
analytics HDFS environment so as the
gentleman was saying if you have
different types of applications with
different requirements and different SLA
is that it becomes even more problematic
at that point but you're correct yeah
the application is now describes how
your day is going to be laid out in
access and the application doesn't know
anything about yes yeah so the
application just you know allocates the
data if it does replications it does the
replication you know natively as it
always does but underneath everything is
managed the whole idea here is to move
the data to the right ear and pay the
right amount of cost for each bit that
you say so you know the whole stack as
far as you know very expensive storage
you know a main memory all the way to
ddrs and then to flash and all the way
down to SAS and SATA and eventually tape
and so on you know obviously a cost per
I up and cost per a gigabit or a
gigabyte that changes a lot based on
that now there is a shifting paradigm in
storage and you know different types of
technologies that we are actually
looking at and different types of
cadence is going forward so for hard
disk and SSD flash and then storage
class memory you know these are the
targets and and you know these are
the trends that we see over the next two
or three years and the source of this
information is the market trends and
also some of the road map discussions we
have with with our partners and our
vendors and the companies that we
interact with so you know as far as the
hdd's are concerned you know within a
year within two years you know we're
expecting to see temperate 10 terabytes
for it for hdd's a solid state you know
in a couple of years we are expecting to
see 24 terabyte actually we have some
samples right now for terabyte SSDs we
are running the two terabytes am song in
some of our solutions and as far as the
flash pcie you know nvme is definitely
something that we see a lot of traction
in the industry we see a lot of roadmap
products that we know will be announced
this year and next year early part of
next year with pcie nvme both in a small
form factor and also card form factor in
server and you know those are the type
of trends that we see in the industry
and then storage class memory you know
that's the you know carbon nanotube
resistive Ram and and all those types of
you know different technologies so as a
conclusion I have this slide you know
the changes and you know the challenges
and the opportunities that we see in
this and in this whole storage
environment story is very very
interesting now you know if you talked
about storage maybe 10 years ago you
wouldn't see this many innovation you
know this much innovation and this much
activity in this area but but right now
you know we have some challenges we have
some opportunities on the right hand
side you see you know the near-term type
of opportunities that we see and at the
bottom you know the five year plus so
you know stuff like you know the
paradigm shifts and you know you know
different types of media you know the
failure domains is you know one of the
concern is there as your storage racks
get more dense you know it and then you
have a separation of storage and compute
you know as the rack goes down or if you
lose connectivity to that rack you
basically lose connectivity from all the
servers that are pointing to it and
obviously you know as these things
become more and more dense you have more
CPU more servers in front of you know
the storage racks and and then you have
to deal with how do you you know how do
you manage the environment how do you
manage the risk and that kind of stuff
and everything again it's a TCO
conversation for us we have to see every
new technology we bring in we have to
actually see how it works in our TCO
model we have a very extensive you
notice your modeling as far as you know
with with everything built in so is to
cost of ownership costs of operation
capex our PEX you know cost of
electricity and you know if facilities
everything else so and we have it down
to you know a sub dollar as far as you
know how much each rack each floor tile
and everything else cost for us so it
has to play and you know every solution
that we look at and we propose we have
to actually justify that within our TCO
models oh so you know and also number
five there you know the new media's and
on her eyes and that's something we were
very excited about something that we
have some traction with you know some
companies in the industry that you know
they're there you know working hard
anantara one of them crossbar another
one you know these are the HP you know
these are you know we're really hopeful
to see some products come up and also
very very interested in that 3d
solutions 3d NAND solutions
and so on and so forth so you know
basically of these are the opportunities
and we're actually looking to see who
can provide or you know which which
companies which solution providers can
provide the type of functionality that
we are asking for and you know have you
know the type of products out there that
we can consume so that's all I had any
questions any concerns yeah follow fears
back from facebook who came here and he
was pushing this angle wanting
manufacturers to drive down the cost of
flash and we want to write once flash
and does this make any sense to you have
you seen any traction that direction is
just really low cost flash that you only
really reliably right once oh we don't
need no right once is not a use case for
us but a drive writes per day a low
drive racks per day it's something that
we're actually asking for a lot of the
vendors have very high Endurance's in
their flash devices and when we you know
really look at our use cases we don't
really need you know ten driver as per
day we just need a good enough but at a
lower at a lower price and that's what
we need but you know just basically
write it once and never write again we
hardly have any use case for that yes so
what's your experience in terms of just
playing blogs on the firmware on there a
chance to see yes these things
fundamentally work yes so the SSDs they
fundamentally work they work differently
with different manufacturers so if we
get four samples from from four
different companies we see some kind of
a difference as far as performance and
the way they handle the i/o so you know
when we know when we do the performance
characterization it's obvious that you
know
slender is better than the other vendor
because it handles a lot better under
circumstance certain circumstances but
we haven't had any major issues that the
technology is not available technology
we haven't seen that at all as a matter
of fact we have a huge deployment of
flash in our environment and you know it
I mean aside from the regular issues
that you would expect we haven't seen
any and anything unexpected software
between you and the real flash so yes so
yeah so you have the FTL you have the
drivers you have the OS and is that what
you were asking or yes yes yeah
definitely yeah yeah we're just you know
we are just a consumer of flash so you
know we rely on all the layers tell you
this mismatch between expected what
flash does well and what you can ask it
to do yes so we have the battery of
tests that and profiling tests that we
want and you know we just we just hammer
the device and we keep stats and you
know depending on who's underneath we
can't characterize that with with the
whole Staten on top of mrs. your
furniture the question is how well can
you exploit it we can well primarily use
VD bench as as one of our test cases or
tools and with VD bench you can actually
have different characteristics so you
can control the IRS and they are they
assumed it so hard disk but I have they
assumed that you assume that it is a
hard disk what is it's not a hard day's
going oh yes so no no so so we actually
characterize it as a flash device we
don't characterize it as a as a hard
disk
you